belgium region's proposed bans on halal
and kosher slaughter is set to come into
force
next month remove those tested the right
type balance in eu legislation between
animal welfare and religious freedom
a halal and kosher slaughter requires
animals to be alive and healthy they're
killed by having their next cut
pre-stunning is not widely used which is
one of the reasons why the practice is
banned in several eu countries
the new law in a region of belgium
though has third controversy among the
country's jewish and
muslim communities to have the
government interfere in this way is
damaging to the reputation of the jewish
people as a community
it implies that we as a group are
irresponsible with the welfare of
animals and need government supervision
which is of course
a very negative view of us we're joined
live by slovenian philosophers lavoisier
thanks for joining us secretary having
the program today
um i suppose these sorts of questions
yeah i suppose these sorts of questions
really put officials in a bit of an
awkward position
don't they balancing animal welfare and
religious freedom which
a lot of european states pride
themselves on um do you think it's even
possible
to keep that balance here without
somebody getting upset
well the first thing i would have done i
don't know the situation in great detail
is to question the political background
of this
decision i don't think it is
necessarily a leftist decision
politically we should never forget
that there is in europe a long tradition
of uh let's call it right-wing
ecology the most devastating
critique i'm aaronic here of hitler
i heard in germany almost 30 years ago
when some right-wing ecologists in a
group where we were debating
were accused of pronouncing sympathies
and you know what they said they said
no we are opposed to hitler okay hitler
did some good things
he got rid of jews and so on but he did
some horrible things
he built highways railways and so on and
so on
this is the right wing green tradition
and in it's very important then in this
case
it's like at both parties
that is to say halal
and kosher i think this also points in
the direction of the extreme
right for whom ultimately
islamists and jews are part of the same
plot to destroy western europe and so on
and so on
you know always we have to
bear in mind this background what
furthermore makes me suspicious
frankly is that
is that why all of a sudden the focus
on these animals it may surprise you but
i know the details
about how they are slaughtered for halal
for porsche
and so on and it's done in a relatively
straightforward way
although i have no sympathy for animal
sacrifices it's done
in a straightforward way without
any excessive torture of animals
whatever i mean if you are just somebody
concerned with
shuttering of animals wouldn't it be
more logical to begin
with what happens on a daily basis
in our industrial agriculture
raising peaks racing chicken and so on
and so on
that's something i want to ask you as
well so to jump in i want to get as many
questions as
i can because you know the media has
taken up this story
um quite widely because there's
obviously this idea of conflict you know
between
traditional christian values or secular
values in many countries in france for
example
and religious groups like the muslim the
jewish population
as you quite rightly say though regular
livestock regular meat
you know doesn't live in the greatest
conditions there's been lots of cases of
animal cruelty recorded in
slaughterhouse
um yet nobody seems to pay so much
attention to that why do you think the
media is quick to pick up on this story
i think it's this is a clear indication
of the political background
that it's really if i may use this
slightly paranoia
terms right wing
racist measure masked
by ecological concerns but i find a kind
of a poetic justice
in the fact that both sides again
the jewish side and the muslim side are
affected
because you know lately the entire
region of the middle east is turning
into something
uh very strange let me tell you a story
which
i checked it with my friends is true
you know that in the middle east around
a year ago
a big religious leader said that
according to the sacred
writings when the soldiers of their
country occupy a foreign country they
have the right
right to rape local women now we will
say some crazy
arab fundamentalists no it was the great
rabbi of idf of israel defense forces
and so on and so forth so sometimes just
so that we don't buy this cliche
enlightened israelis versus primitive
muslims
is good to focus on the entire
area but nonetheless this may sound
unpleasant for some
unites the two and what surprised me in
the brief quote
from the jewish activist there
that you just that we were able to hear
it's again i would have expected a
little bit of
solidarity at least here muslims and
jews are
on the same side affected by a
prohibition
no this guy mentioned only the jewish
side which makes me
very sad i mean europe prides itself on
multicultural
multiculturalism doesn't it the uk for
one country as well
of multiculturalism and here very clear
i claim that multiculturalism has limits
and you know where are these limits
if you talk with some muslim real
fundamentalists you see them immediately
it's never just let different cultures
co-exist the problems explode
when different cultures which exist in
the same
country when they interact for example
in germany
there are literally around 2 000
examples
every year where a girl from some
muslim family wants to live more western
style of life boyfriends
nightclubs and so on and abandons her
family takes
refuge and there you have to decide
there is no
third way do you give her back to the
family
or do you do you protect her if you give
her back to the family
of course a feminist will explode i mean
if you
protect her islamists will say oh you
are affecting our way of life and so on
and so on
we have to make a choice here and i am
on the side of this of course more open
choice
if the girl feels oppressed by her not
only her family her culture
the state has to protect